welcome back to the five president biden
taking some time away from his fancy
dancy vacation in nantucket to repeat
his america's back message on the most
expensive thanksgiving in history oh
hold on my phone's ringing just a sec oh
my gosh look at who's calling oh
hello hello
hello mr brother wow how you doing pal
it's so good
good for you calling we thank you so
much what's
what's your message to the american
folks on this thanksgiving day my
message is after two years you're back
america is back there's nothing we're
unable to overcome out
that was a spontaneous call uh and
biden's allies trying to back him up uh
back up is out of touch comments
elizabeth warren claiming prices are
surging because of quote greedy
corporations and not democrats and
republicans are ripping biden saying it
looks like he's doing things on purpose
you want to buy a home it's going to
cost more you want to rent an apartment
it's going to cost more to put food on
the table it costs more to put gas in
your car it costs more and of course
thanksgiving turkey and now christmas
presents all cost more what they're
doing to the price of goods and services
has to be intentional with their crazy
spending and now they're going to make
it even worse by putting tax increases
if they pass this plan putting tax
increases on the very people who've been
busting their tail trying to try to help
their family over the last several
months
all right jessica i'm gonna go to you
first because i'm gonna give you the
shot at this one isn't joe biden truly
out of touch in nantucket 20 million
dollar estate as americans are 30
million 30 million
30 million dollars nobody's staying
there as we're as we're trying to just
pump up our cars and buy a turkey he's
like in nantucket
i'm sorry you're suffering i am i have
nine kids come on
a lot of people do have a lot of
children this the
house for just one
that seems
a little crazy so
oh lord have mercy more uh
so the bidens have been going into
nantucket since 1975. just to put that
in context this is a long tradition in a
30 million dollar estate
so they are same with bradley
all right you got to let our talk yeah
all right if you let me go
first let me do it and then i will be
quiet so
for people who are upset about this
i question are you upset that donald
trump paid spent 141 million dollars on
golf outings right someone who literally
had a golden toilet in their house
didn't aggravate people that are upset
that joe biden is hanging out with a
high millionaire probably billionaire
donor that's what people do and a
tradition that's gone for a long time
the real problem for democrats on this
is that when you go to the grocery store
and you go to the gas pump you do see
that prices are higher then at the same
time there are some very positive things
happening like the unemployment numbers
lowest claims in 52 years we saw
retailers will open more stores than
close them for the first time since
2017. so how do democrats work
work that out right without telling
people you know don't believe your lion
eyes right but also saying that there
are some positive things that are
happening in the economy and that we
hope post-pandemic that we're going to
be really completely back on our feet
well i would just say that donald trump
actually paid for those golden toilets
and he lived down the street he never
said he was from scranton new jersey and
like poor you know donald trump he was
like a billionaire and he and he owned
it they don't have a screen but yeah
you're not claiming that
okay so joe so but so things are so
great we're actually tapping the
strategic oil reserve trying to pump
more oil into the uh into the reserves
so we actually can bring prices down
that doesn't sound like things are going
so well well no because it's only what
50 million barrels and what do we use
the energy secretary didn't know when
she was asked it's 18 million a day so
that buys you like three days or
something like that 2.6 i think that the
president
instead of calling al roker maybe uh in
waukesha maybe call some of those
families that are suffering right now
they have
family members in the hospital children
in the hospital grandmothers that were
killed in that crash he's barely talked
about that i would have gone to
wisconsin before i go to nantucket he
also says that america is back i think
he means back in 1979 because that's
what we're dealing with with inflation
supply chain gas prices and an unstable
afghanistan middle east in essence right
so america is back not quite just over a
quarter one quarter of this country says
that this country is on the right track
right now if that's back
i'd rather be back in 1970 and waukesha
didn't really vote for him but they
would appreciate a visit from him no
doubt from their president right and by
the way the golden toilet thing if you
have a golden toilet wouldn't you get a
duvet i mean go all the way with it
because duvets are very underrated i i
can't answer that well all right
but taken you know you meant a bidet
yeah because i do raise your comments
you said it but today is a comforter you
said it
maybe that's how joe does it i don't
know if our viewers care
expert here so let's talk about
elizabeth warren saying it's the fault
of corporations for rising prices it's
not the fault of democrats and spending
and borrowing
what's your take
uh of course she would turn and blame
profiteering because again those evil
businesses because i i suppose that the
government if they took them over
in a uh central plan communist society
uh the government that's done such a
crackerjack job on
the virus would do a better job again
it's create a prop this is binding
company create a problem
blame somebody else and then use
demagoguery to completely shirk
accountability elizabeth warren using
that language is is just like joe biden
kind of writing a letter to the federal
trade commission saying you need to
investigate gouging as if that that's
the problem again it's to deflect but
biden coupling literally only have words
now
because the truth is in aisle five and
americans know that and the truth is
that when you go to fill up your car but
jessica brought up the jobless claims
numbers
of all the numbers the jobless claims
numbers were that's the number of people
filing for first-time unemployment
benefits and it's every week it was a
big deal at the height of the pandemic
when so many people were getting laid
off now
it's laughable that they're trying to
make a show out of that number when the
real issue is people won't take jobs
that there are almost 10 and a half
million job openings in this country the
jobless claims numbers the by
administration crowing about that is
like you're losing 35 to nothing in a
football game and you score in the
fourth quarter a field goal and then
you're running around the field like you
just won the super bowl that's how
idiotic it is yeah so joey when we talk
about being out of touch uh harris was
in paris
and she bought a 375 dollar serving dish
and a 160 dollar frying pan yeah maybe
setting herself up for next career i'm
not sure because the poll numbers are in
the tank and i don't know if she's going
to be in politics much longer listen at
the end of the day don't spit in my face
and tell me it's raining fox news is a
great place to get fair and balanced
information but people aren't sitting at
home saying things are bad because we're
the ones telling them that they're
saying things are bad because they're
living it they're experiencing it and
they're worried and if you're president
of the united states maybe show them you
can connect with that if that's what you
actually ran on donald trump didn't run
on sharing our finances he ran on the
idea that he would say what we were
thinking but afraid to say out loud
joe biden ran on saying he's scranton
joe blue-collar joe yeah that was the
poorest member of the senate when he
left that's his stick that's who he is
in a billionaire thanksgiving doesn't
fit in a time unlike when donald trump
was going golfing people are worried
about their finances i remember 2017 and
2018 they were good years for me and
more importantly they were good years
for my family that that has really
scratched and worked really hard in this
in his life harder than than i have and
that's where people are back where is
america back to
i mean for a lot of people 2009 and
that's what's tough yeah
i got to think though that house in
nantucket has a day you know what
every president has rich friends and
they go to fancy places on vacation
everyone in modern history except for
jimmy carter who was hanging out at his
peanut farm
that's not the big deal the policy is
the problem well we serve democrats
really well as they channel the little
bill clinton and say i feel your pain
and you can actually you know
acknowledge what people are going
through instead of rushing off to
nantucket hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else